this great big story was made possible
by Wells Fargo established 1852
reestablished 2018 when it comes to
horror movies there's an actor who is so
good at his job his performance has
stayed with you like a nightmare he just
can't wake up from
but trust us he's a really nice guy
let's go
I'm Xavier Valdez and I'm an actor and
how the airs been in a lot of movies you
probably just didn't see him because
well he looks quite different most of
the time I feel very comfortable in
monster roles I believe if mama country
to create some peak Slender Man and
let's not forget he's been in the mummy
and alien - I'm very scary Island 2
metres tall and 56 kilograms
it's not a problem of eating because I
love to eat it's a personal condition is
call it a Marfan syndrome
Javier's career started when he met a
prosthetic makeup teacher in Madrid this
led to Javier's first monster role in
the movie beneath still waters
that was my first makeup my first work
in a real movie and well after that all
the makeup artists start seeing my work
and start proposing me in other roles
Alessia I've been working in 8 or 9
different shows there's gonna be some
behind-the-scenes gossip them yeah well
I I was in crimson peak I was out of all
the makeup and I was the last day with
the year model total and I say Tom
Hiddleston and I said okay see you it
was a pleasure and he said who are you
so I say I was your ex-wives okay okay
okay yeah sorry I didn't recognize you
but don't pigeonhole this guy he might
be a monster most of the time but he's
got dramatic range
okay guys you already really love what
you do because it's going to be hard to
long journey be prepare you never know
what's gonna happen Tom be shy don't let
fear paralyze you so relax you know what
I mean if I can ask for something I
loved I would love to be a big seed I
will rule the galaxy
[Music]
[Music]